there is new confusion over what the cdc
is recommending its effort to slow the
search in covet cases here we go the
agency is sticking with guidance on how
long people should isolate but tried to
clarify its advice on testing in the
meantime president biden is appealing
for more americans to please get
vaccinated wishing is at the white house
to sort it all out rija good morning and
good luck
good morning to you and good morning
everybody the cdc is doubling down on
its guidance that people who test
positive for covid19 can stop their
isolation after five days if they are
still asymptomatic or feeling mildly ill
and those people are still not required
to get a negative test result first
however the cdc added a caveat if
someone has access to a test and wants
to take one then they may and those who
test positive should isolate for another
five days the cdc is also encouraging
people coming out of isolation to
continue wearing that mask for an
additional five days now last week when
it scaled back the isolation period from
ten to five days many outside health
experts worried that that was too soon
to ensure that the patient is no longer
contagious without getting a test
yesterday the cdc posted new data that
shows most transmission happens early in
the infection this all comes as the u.s
is seeing a nationwide shortage of those
at home test kits the federal government
is launching a website this month for
people to order a test to be shipped for
free and president biden also announced
that he plans to double the order for
pfizer's anti-viral pill from 10 million
to 20 million with the first half
available
likely in june tony
all right wiesha thank you very much